EMERGING RIGHT.
"THE WNGREPORTING TH NEW YORK H
TRUMP SHOULD BE DICTED A
OF THEIR INTO HI
WHAT DO WEW ABOUT THIS
THIS SOUNDS SO, SO PTI
INVESTIGEN GNIFICANT, WOLF.GEST
VE BEES TERING ITS F
LOOKING AT WHETHER THE
ORGANIZA LD ABOUT ITS
O DEFRAUD INSUNCCOMPANIES AND BN
THEY HAD MORAN WHETHERD TO THEO
SAYING THEY WETSLD PAY LOWER TA?
NOW FORMER TRUMP ISN'TTHE ONLY
POTENTIALLY BE IN LEGA
HERE.
IGATORVEG
ATVES ANE
COMPANY ITSELF.
NOW ACCORDINE ST" THISRY WILL ME
IX MONTHS,ND
IT APPEAIS
T THE ONLYR BEFORE THIS
PARTICULAR GRAND JURY.
E WATCHING ALL ,
UNFOLD BECAUSE IT COMES ASRU LA
6tSURREC
WASH
THE FIRSTIE FORMER IGHT, WOLF, S
PRESIDENT HAS FORMALLYPO
T DEMOCRATICTIVE ETRYING THERE P
IN HIS ARGUMENTS HO FOR THE
UMENTS TO DEFEND MSELF AND HIMEH
ISSU T O
6tURAGING THEM TSE
SPEECH.E RSNALLYS TOHERELTNT ISS
T INCITE AN , AND THFIRST ARGUMT
LUITY BECAUSE HE WASCAPACITY AS
ADMINISTRATION HE WAS FREQUENTLY
LIMITS OF EXECE
LAWSUIT HDISMISSED THIS KIND O.
AS TWHR THT WILL
PIE
THANKS SO MUCH
S WITHCORDOR JOINING
D JU
ED?
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
epPAUL
INK ITOES T IFICANT NEW STEP
RIERS THAT T ATIPRESIDENCY, SO L
ORGANIZATION ITS KOIMP
KA T FMEPRESIDENT,
AND TH ITSELF. A IND
D  FACT THJU
FORMER
PRESIDENT WOULD FACE CHA WELL,
RING A CAS THE
RETURNS
AGI THINK
TOO SOON FOR US TOWHAT TYATION H
REPORT THAT JUST CE OUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE THD JURY IS JUST SIL
SO I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
ABOUT THE GRANRY AS WELL RECENT
CAME FROM THRK ATTORNEY
INVESTIGATN,ND NG HER CRIM
S INVESTIGATION AND
REALLY NLLD
EXPECT FROM PROSECUTORS IS
E HEAREM
DOCUMENT. HAVE A CHARGING
>> THEENT,S YOU SO FACING SOME
LEGAL ISSUES.
HE HIS ROLE IN THE
JA6th ONFOR
PAULAE
T
SPEE FAT DAYS
PROTECTED UNTHAMENT,E HAD
RDS -- HE HAABS PRESIDEN CONTEST
AT THA
GUI MOUNT
ARGUMENT IS PROBABLYHE WEA
GHTO DEMDYAS IEN OR, YOUTHE RIO
AFTER HICH.
TH IMMUNITY I THK IS
WEAKER, ER ONE, BECAUSE THAT
VERY,Y BROAD ASSERTION
TH ASSERTED SOTIVEPRIVILEGE ORE
ASSER
TO
BRD THE
FACTHEE PRESIDENT WA
SPAKING  SPEAKING AS SOMEONE WHN
AS CANDIDATE
IT REALLY WASN'T A PRESIDENT
TI THAT HE WAS IN.
HE,
BUT FOR THOSE REASONS THAT THAU.
IT'S SOMETHINGE TRUMP
ORGANION ARGUED.
TH A IN HIACHMENT AS
ASSERTED ING SPIN OTHG  REGARDG
CONVERTI ADVISERS,REGARDINWILEG.
IT'S USUALLYOT S